.
I AM SERIOUS.
THINK ABOUT IT.
>> HERE FOR REACTION.
CLAY TRAVIS AND FOX ACROSS
AMERICA HOST JIMMY.
CLAY, YOUR PICK, SINGING, F-16S.
>> I WILL START.
JOE BIDEN SANG HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO
SOMEONE STILL ALIVE.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> PART OF ME THOUGHT HALFWAY
THROUGH HE WOULD SEND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO MLK OR JFK OR RFK.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHO IS ALIVE OR
DEAD.
IT IS MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
GRANDSO
GRANDSON.
I WILL LET JIMMY DIVE IN.
THESE ARE SUCH GREAT STORIES TO
REACT TO.
>> JIMMY?
>> THANKS FOR THE HAND OFF.
>> A NICE SUIT ALWAYS.
>> THANK YOU.
FORGIVE THE ANALOGY JOE BIDEN
SINGING HAPPY BIRTHDAY IS AS
CLOSE TO THE VIKINGS WINNING
PLAYOFF GAMES.
>> TOO SOON!
>> WAY TOO SOON.
>> AREN'T YOU A JETS FAN?
>> TRAVIS, STAY ON YOUR SIDE OF
THE SCREEN.
WE ARE BAGGING ON BIDEN HARD.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS.
DEEP DOWN, THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
TEAM IS SO RELIEVED HE DIDN'T
CALL IT RODNEY KING DAY.
THEY ARE HAVING A DRINK IN THE
PRESS OFFICE, THANK GOD.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN SO MUCH
WORSE.
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
WITH THE DOCUMENTS TALK AM THERE
IS NO WAY THIS MAN IS RUNNING
AGAIN.
AT THIS POINT 2024 IS HUNTER'S
BLOOD ALCOHOL CONTENT AND
NOTHING MORE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I THINK HE WILL RUN AGAIN.
>> YOU DO?
>> I THINK THIS IS JUST
INCOMPETENCE BY JONES-DREW.
THE FIX CAN'T BE IN TO TAKE JOE
BIDEN IN BECAUSE IT REQUIRES SO
MUCH INCOMPETENCE BY HIM.
HE IS REALLY BAD AT THIS.
I WOULD POINT THIS OUT.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS
SOMEBODY AT THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES SECRETLY CONTACTED THE
BIDEN TEAM AND SAID LOOK THERE
IS A LOT OF HEAT OVER WHAT TRUMP
HAS AND DOESN'T HAVE.
WE WENT INTO THE ARCHIVES AND
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT THAT JOE
BIDEN KEPT.
WE CAN'T FIND THIS DOCUMENT.
WE THINK YOU GUYS HAVE IT.
OTHERWISE THE STORE
Y BIDE.
DO YOU HIRE LAWYERS TO BE YOUR
MOVING COMPANY?
NO, THEY WERE LOOKING FOR
SOMETHING.
THIS IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE MOVES
OF ALL TIME.
THEY FOUND.
THEY DIDN'T JUST DESTROY IT OR
BURN IT OR SHRED IT BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THEY HAD TO HAVE IT.
THAT WILL TIE ALL OF THIS
TOGETHER.
I THINK THEY WILL RUN.
THEY WILL DRAG HIM ACROSS THE
FINISH LINE AS MUCH AS THEY NEED
TO.
>> JIMMY, YOU USED UNPAID
INTERNS TO MOVE YOUR OFFICE.
YOU KNOW ABOUT LOSING TRACK OF
THINGS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> TO BE CLEAR, THE PEOPLE
MOVING BY OFFICE THEY ARE NOT
GETTING PAID IT MOVE.
THEY ARE GETTING PAID HUSH MONEY
FOR WHAT IS GOING ON IN THE
LIQUOR CABINENT.
HERE'S THE BODY LINE.
CLAY IS RIDE.
.
-- RIOT.
RIGHT.
BIDEN'S TEAM THEY ALL GET TO BE
PRESIDENT.
THIS WHOLE PRESIDENCY IS AN
iTUNES USER AGREEMENT.
THEY MAKE BIDEN SCROLL TO THE
BOTTOM WITHOUT READING ANYTHING
AND CLICK I AGREE.
THEN YOU REOPEN THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BUMP HIM OFF.
THE GUY IS SMOKING LIKE A YARD
OF WEED PER EPISODE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> YOU DABBLE INTO A DOOZY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO THE JIMM